[Music]
it's not that
I lost my lead dog Oh we'll be two days
behind if you're lucky and we never been
lucky
[Music]
you might wanna hang on yeah give it and
mush
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey watch yourself
[Music]
[Music]
that's mine hey thanks the Yukon is a
dangerous place you never know what's
coming I came up here because I didn't
want to be around anyone and then I met
buck he was a dog like no other even
spoiled
[Music]
and he'd suffered
[Music]
but he could not be broken
I don't know where you came from but I
know where you are now welcome to the
last place on the earth I should let him
have a minute doesn't look like he's
ever seen snow before how do you feel
about an adventure
no Maps we should go
you and I or no one's ever been before
[Music]
see what's out there
[Music]
good you're enjoying this
I never saw him believe in anything as
much as he believes in you
[Music]
what do you say bucket
adventure of a lifetime
you know sleeping for two days in my bed
I got dogs all my life they're older
they have personalities buck in John
Thornton's case when he finds buck he
finds a companion for an adventure the
changes John Thornton's life it changes
Buck's life
I never saw him believe in anything
as much as he believes in you are you
coming get in here come on and give them
affection companionship and in turn they
will love you
yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]